I mean only at time 100 I feel like
we've got Ronan Pharaoh Mia Pharaoh
Megan McCain here I mean it's just a
collision of influential people and one
of the most influential people in your
life I would imagine Megan is being
honored tonight yeah it's incredible I
she told me last night that my parents
and Bill and Hillary Clinton and the
Bill and Melinda Gates are only three
couples in the history to be nominated
as like couple separately which is such
an amazing I think statistic in fact
yeah so I'm so proud of her and all the
work she's doing with the where all the
food program and trying to solve world
hunger and it's just you know it's
really special my dad has passed five
years in August and to have you honored
in this way is just really beautiful and
my heart is with you and I know so many
would say that how have you been doing
after I'm doing very well thank you all
right now I'm the executive director for
the will approved program and so I live
in Rome and I'm working on you know of
stopping hunger worldwide that's my job
now that is incredible to put that love
and passion into something that you're
obviously equally as passionate thank
you in a different platform how are you
doing it mom she is like the hardest
working woman in this industry
no I mean you know I work in TV too
sometimes and you are seriously the
hardest worker you do such a good job
they're so lucky to have you
this is a hard job at this event so we
gotta give props to people doing on the
other side because sometimes it just
makes the brain it's explosive taking up
former gigs sometimes things get a
little explosive over on The View so you
tune in from time to time since you've
Departed the show never I never watch
anything well I actually don't really
watch it's funny I'm a cord cutter now
so I don't my husband we like moved and
then we were like should we install
cable and I was like let's just not and
it's actually like lovely to choose Your
Entertainment I do watch Entertainment
Tonight
You Know show but um yeah I really just
choose which shows I want to watch now
which is fabulous so fair enough and
will you will you be tuning in to the
show that is the King's coronation
coming up I mean it's just days away of
course it's gonna be oh yeah yeah she
watched the um when The Royal Wedding
like she stayed up late like the night
before and dressed up in town yeah my
mom's like a total
foreign